[Applaudissements]
mais s'agir qui a laissé un message pour
qui tu verras keen'v puisqu'on a fait
danser avec les stars ensemble est-ce
que tu serais capable d'apprendre un
cyril quelques pas de cha cha et faut-il
y voir
je suis déjà passer pour un con pendant
quatre mois à essayer apprendre à danser
alors si quelqu'un qui n'est pas dense
et apprend à danser tu vas là encore
plus d'un compte donc non alors sinon je
viens essayer mais alors à michèle
laroque et marc vanhecke nous a aidés
[Applaudissements]
attention à moi d'accueillir camille
combal et j'espère qu'on accueillera pas
daniel guichard bien sûr à on espère
qu'il n'arrivera pas avant la fin de
l'émission qui devait aller
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on fait